the people of the United States and
really the people of the world have been
the targets of or I think really I would
say the victims of a war on statistics a
war on reality from the Trump
administration
I've talked for a very long time this is
one of my passion areas right how to lie
with statistics a number of people in
the labor force we've talked about labor
force participation when it's a Democrat
Republicans like to say record number of
people not working when it's a
Republican right now under Donald Trump
you hear record number of people are
working and as I've explained to you
before when the population of the United
States keeps growing the raw number of
people working or not working doesn't
really tell us very much about the state
of the economy as this isolated out of
context number I've talked about gas
lighting around unemployment numbers as
well which under Obama from the Bureau
of Labor Statistics were untrustworthy
numbers that had been doctored that we
simply can't trust and now under the
Trump administration those same numbers
from the same agency are what we point
to to say look at how great the economy
is doing if you were Trump or his
cronies but what I want to talk about
today is not just unemployment numbers
but unemployment and GDP numbers gross
domestic product I recently brought you
the story of Donald Trump and his
cronies going around claiming that GDP
growth was at historic highs much higher
than ever during the Obama presidency
and it was simply untrue they've now
come up with a really great sounding lie
that combines GDP and unemployment into
a very neat little story that to a lot
of people is impacting them even though
it's meaningless and it's a distortion
and that is according to this tweet from
Donald Trump that the GDP growth rate is
higher than the unemployment rate for
the first time
in more than 100 years there are two
levels of analysis to do here first is
is the claim true second is even if it's
true does it tell us anything important
about the state of the economy so let's
start with part one is it true no it's
not I'm going to put up a graph for you
here which has two lines the white line
is GDP the yellow line is unemployment
and as those who are watching along with
me can see the white GDP line has
exceeded the yellow unemployment line
many many times and this graph goes back
only to about 1950 now according to
Bloomberg about 20 percent of the time
over the last hundred years the GDP has
exceeded the unemployment rate so
question one is is this an accurate
statement about GDP and unemployment
from Donald Trump the answer's no it's
it's a total bold-faced provable lie but
I want to talk about the more important
part which is whether it's true or not
does it tell us anything does it tell us
anything to compare an annualized
quarterly GDP growth rate with
unemployment numbers that are reported
for the previous month the answer is it
tells us nothing okay first and foremost
GDP as I mentioned is measured quarterly
and unemployment numbers are monthly so
you have what's called a time horizon
conflict in comparing these numbers
basic just basic statistical of
ignorance taking place when you make
that comparison secondly Donald Trump
said in his tweet that GDP growth was
4.2 percent it wasn't 4.2 percent last
quarter it was 1.0 5% but what Donald
Trump is doing is taking that quarter of
GDP growth and multiplying it by four
why multiply it by four because that is
the estimated yearly GDP growth rate if
last quarter repeats three more times
that makes no sense when you are
comparing that to monthly unemployment
numbers
taking an annualized quarterly number
and comparing it to a monthly
unemployment number and then lastly
there are reasons that unemployment can
be up or down which can be good or bad
you need to understand what's going on
that's causing it there are also ways as
I've told you before that GDP can be up
that aren't necessarily indicative of a
great economy for example if businesses
learn that big tariffs are coming think
about it they will decide or they might
decide to pre-purchase a bunch of raw
materials before those tariffs hit this
can increase GDP now at the expense of
GDP later so bottom line this is an
untrue claim but more importantly it
doesn't tell us anything material about
how the economy is doing but the problem
is that the average trumpet is so lost
in space around economic indicators
trade which has been a big topic of
gaslighting by Donald Trump
all of the things Trump campaigned on
the idea that listen if it sounds good
it's going to work on the trumpets and
that's all Trump wants but it is total
ignorance it's not cognitive dissonance
it's ignorance it's people who don't
know or understand what they're talking
about following a guy who is equally
ignorant about basic money and economic
issues
like this don't fall for this stuff
because it will truly rot your brain you
can give me a follow on Twitter at Dee
Pakman you can also follow the show at
David Pakman show we will take a quick
break and be back after this today's
program is sponsored in part by Blink
accom slash Pakman if you've not already
heard about blink Asst it's amazing it's
an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a fifteen minute
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a
ton of books on blinken recent one is a
Robert Rice's new book the common good
also bunk by Kevin Young useful in
preparing me for the pseudoscience
miniseries that we're producing and if
you are a david pakman show viewer or
listener you can get a seven day free
trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on youtube use
the link in the video description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/pa ke ma n